[Musik]
liebe genossinnen und genossen liebe
gäste
zu unserem fünfzehnten geburtstag
faellt mir ich muss sagen kein rechter
glückwunsch 1 da wir uns in einer
existenziellen krise befinden das müssen
wir alle begreifen
wenn es junge leute gibt die sich
vorstellen dass man die partei auch
krachen lassen kann und dann baut man
eine fantastische neue partei auf stecke
ich lediglich fest dass das mit den
realitäten nichts zu tun hat
wir verloren
wir gehören alle mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter alle büros sämtliche
einrichtungen die
rosa-luxemburg-stiftung und es gibt
keine bewegung die in breiter masse zu
einer neugründung bereit ist entweder
wir hätten unsere partei oder wir
versinken in bedeutungslosigkeit
das ist meines erachtens
dafür erforderlich
wir müssen neu darüber nachdenken was
unser zweck für die gesellschaft ist
wenn wir diesen zweck kennzeichnen
können wir uns auf wesentliche fragen
konzentrieren und müssen alle
unwesentlichen fragen beiseite lassen
wir brauchen im augenblick
keine anträge zur trennung von amt und
mandat
denn wenn wir so weitermachen wie bisher
verlieren wir ohnehin alle mandaten dann
haben wir die absolute trennung es geht
auch nicht
es geht auch nicht um die dauer von
mandaten ich spreche immer in weiblicher
und männlicher vorn die rechtsanwältin
hat ein recht darauf rechtsanwältin zu
sein und ich habe ein recht darauf
rechtsanwalt zu sein aber wir brauchen
jetzt ich hoffe es gibt ein paar buch
was kommt da noch was aber wir brauchen
jetzt weder anträge noch beschlüsse zum
doppelpunkt zum großen oder zum
sternchen ich bin auch nicht bereit zu
machen
[Applaus]
das gehobene bürgertum dass diese
schreibweise fordert will ja nicht die
verhältnisse verändern
die frauen diverse und viele andere
benachteiligen es will nur die
schreibweise verändern wir aber wollen
die verhältnisse verändern
auf welche fragen dass wir uns
konzentrieren
erstens geht es um eine reale
friedenspolitik ich wiederhole die eu
und die nato haben in bezug auf russland
und die ukraine alles falsch gemacht was
man falsch machen kann aber
aber es war kein fehler dabei der den
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
russlands gegen die ukraine auch nur im
geringsten rechtfertigt
deshalb
deshalb müssen wir diesen kriegsschiff
verurteilen
natürlich probieren sich die usa jetzt
mit waffen gegen russland aus natürlich
wollen sie jetzt russland schwächen aber
wenn man von einem stellvertreterkrieg
spricht darf man nicht vergessen dass
der gar nicht möglich gewesen wäre wenn
russland die ukraine nicht überfallen
hätte
die verantwortung liegt also bei der
russischen führung
natürlich müssen wir kritisch zur nato
bleiben wir müssen auch die mängel in
der eu kritisieren wir dürfen aber nicht
den krieg verurteilen und leichter nach
1 aber setzen und die verurteilung des
krieges damit relativieren
selbstverständlich
[Applaus]
selbstverständlich müssen wir uns für
eine solidarität mit der ukrainischen
bevölkerung und jenen russinnen und
russen einsetzen die mutig gegen den
krieg auftreten
ich bin jetzt
zum vorsitzenden der deutsch polnischen
parlamentariergruppe
berufen worden das heißt ich bin für die
parlament beziehung zu island norwegen
dänemark finnland und schweden zuständig
schweden und finnland wollen nun
mitglieder der nato werden natürlich
sträubt sich in mir alles dagegen wenn
ich sehe die nato kritisch ich habe
betreten beider länder auch gesagt dass
wir nicht weniger sondern mehr
militärisch neutrale staaten zur
vermittlung benötigen sie erwiderten
dass sie diesbezüglich nicht angefragt
wurden in den letzten jahrzehnten und im
übrigen auch als mitglieder der nato
vermitteln können ferner verwies sich
auch den völkerrechtswidrigen krieg der
nato gegen serbien und auf die
völkerrechtswidrige kriege der usa zum
beispiel gegen vietnam und gegen die
iraker sie erwiderten dass sie an
völkerrechtswidrigen kriegen nicht
teilnehmen werden man ist auch als
nato-mitglied nur im verteidigungsfall
dazu verpflichtet und dann sagte ich
dass ich keine sekunde lang glaube dass
russland sie angreifen wird zumal
russland militärisch gerade stark
geschwächte sie erwiderten dass nach dem
krieg russland die armee und die rüstung
wieder aufbauen wird außerdem fragten
sie mich ob ich denn geglaubt hätte dass
russland die ukraine angreift
wahrheitsgemäß antwortete ich dass ich
es nicht geglaubt hatte daraufhin
stellten sie klar dass sie ja nur in die
nato wollten damit einen angriff auf sie
den bündnisfall auslöst und damit den
ersten weltkrieg und den scheuen aller
auch rösler nun meine frage an euch was
soll ich antworten
wir sind entschiedene gegner der
aufrüstungspolitik die die
regierungskoalition und die union
beschließen sie haben gegen unseren
willen die schuldenbremse ins
grundgesetz aufgenommen und würden nun
mit einem kredit von 100 milliarden euro
für die bundeswehr gegen ihre eigene
grundgesetzänderung verstoßen deshalb
greifen sie zu dem trick die 100
milliarden euro als sondervermögen ins
grundgesetz zu schreiben weil sie ihr
dank wieder an das grundgesetz gebunden
sind außerdem wollen sie die jährlichen
ausgaben für die bundeswehr und rüstung
von 50 auf 75 milliarden euro erhöhen es
wird immer wieder erklärt dass vieles in
der bundeswehr nicht funktionieren aber
frankreich gibt es in etwa das gleiche
geld für seine habe aus wie deutschland
und da funktioniert ist also liegt es
doch nicht an der menge des geldes
sondern eher an der art wie es
eingesetzt wird darum sollten sich der
partei- diffus und der
haushaltsausschuss des bundestages
einmal intensiv kümmern
auch die behauptung man brauche dies zum
schutz vor russland ist absurd russland
wird deutschland nicht angreifen in den
beiden bisherigen weltkriegen war es
umgekehrt außerdem
außerdem erinnere ich an die
argumentation von finnland und schweden
dass sie ja in die nato wollen weil es
dank ein angriff russlands gebe
wieso soll das nicht für das
nato-mitglied deutschland kehren und
selbst wenn der angriff geschah hätten
wir den dritten weltkrieg mit
beteiligung der armeen aus den usa
großbritannien frankreich etc von uns
bliebe ohnehin nichts übrig dafür müssen
wir jetzt nicht 100 milliarden euro
verschwendet um es auch mal ganz platt
zu sagen
wir müssen auch entschiedene gegner des
waffenexports durch deutschland bleiben
deutschland hat den zweiten weltkrieg
verursacht und wir haben nie wieder das
recht an kriegen zu verdienen als
fünftgrößter
alsfeld größter waffenexporteur der welt
verdienen wir aber an jedem krieg egal
ob er im nahen osten in afrika oder
sonst stattfindet aber es geht nicht nur
um den staat auf unsere konzerne dürfen
nicht an kriegen verdienen andere länder
haben eine andere geschichte das lösen
wir wiederum respektieren aber wir
werden die verantwortung für unsere
geschichte nicht los wir müssen die
anderen daran hindert die versuchen sie
loszuwerden
reale friedenspolitik heißt dass wir
linken aktiv dafür streiten müssen dass
wir wieder zur deeskalation
abrüstung viel mehr diplomatie
interessenausgleich auch das gegenüber
hat ja interessen und endlich zur
strikten wahrung des völkerrechts durch
alle staaten als grundlage für
internationale beziehungen zurückkehren
und wir müssen das ganze völkerrecht
respekt hier nicht nur die teile die wir
mögen sonst unterscheiden wir uns nicht
von den anderen die es regelmäßig so
praktizieren
die zweite frage
die zweite frage auf die wir uns
konzentrieren müssen ist die frage der
sozialen gerechtigkeit und der guten
arbeit es geht nicht nur um die großen
einkommens und vermögens unterschiede
und die steuergerechtigkeit es geht auch
um mitbestimmungsrechte um die
überwindung der prekären beschäftigung
um die frage was und wie etwas
hergestellt wird welche dienstleistungen
erbracht werden es geht um
chancengleichheit aller kinder und
jugendlichen beim zugang zu bildung
ausbildung
kunst kultur und sport auch zur teuren
sportarten und es geht um renten
richtigkeit im unterschied zu anderen
dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass gerade
durch internet und handy die soziale
frage zu einer menschheitsfrage geworden
ist weltweit findet ein lebensstandards
vergleich stadt und außer abschottung
fällt den herrschenden nichts ein
es gibt aber einen beachtlichen
unterschied bei den linken die einen
wollen die erste klasse bei der
deutschen bahn abschaffen damit alle
menschen zweiter klasse fahren ich bin
da für die zweite klasse abzuschaffen
damit alle zum preis der zweiten klasse
erste klasse war
die einen wollen eher eine allgemeine
armut und ich will er ein allgemeinen
wohlstand wir sollten uns für letzteres
entscheiden
aber im augenblick
stehen dramatische fragen an und uns
allen bevor millionenfache hungersnot
unerträglich steigende wohnungsmieten
kaum fassbare lebensmittel und
energiepreise die regierung hat es mit
zum teil falschen sanktionen auch selbst
verschuldet
leidtragende sind viele menschen
weltweit und auch in unserer bevölkerung
und unverfroren ist es keine extra
steuer wie in italien spanien
griechenland großbritannien von den
mineral und rüstungskonzern für ihre
zusätzlichen gigantischen kriegs gewinne
zu fordern
mein gott wir haben eigentlich so viel
zu tun und womit befassen wir uns alles
die dritte frage
wissen frage nach der ökologischen
nachhaltigkeit in sozialer verantwortung
wir sollten gar nicht erst versuchen
grüner zu sein als die grünen obwohl
diese das grüne ja gerade verlassen wir
müssen immer an die soziale
verantwortung appellieren
wenn die politik einen braunkohlenrevier
schließt muss sie den braunkohle kumpeln
sagen welchen gleich bezahlten job sie
am nachfolgenden tag haben
wenn die politik
eine solche wenn die politik eine solche
schließung beschließt dann trägt sie
auch die soziale verantwortung dafür
teils waters über die befragte industrie
gelegen teils über einen öffentlich
geförderten beschäftigungssektor
die vierte frage ist die frage nach der
gleichstellung von frau und mann unser
ziel ist es dass die frauen weltweit die
gleichen rechte und chancen zu bildung
und ausbildung zur und in der
beruflichen tätigkeit zur beruflichen
politischen gesellschaftlichen karriere
haben letztlich ist es auch eine frage
der sozialen gerechtigkeit und ohnehin
eine menschheitsfrage
fünftens muss es uns um die angleichung
von ost und west gehen das ist auch eine
frage der kulturellen und
psychologischen identitätspolitik wir
brauchen weder für die bisherigen wir
brauchen wieder entschuldigung für die
bisherigen und die neuen medien
aufbereitete informationen mit denen
nachgewiesen wird wie der osten im
vergleich zum westen benachteiligt wird
wir brauchen anträge im bundestag über
die sich die anderen fraktionen ärgern
wo es immer wieder um diese
gleichstellungsfragen geht
selbstverständlich fordern wir gleichen
lohn für gleiche arbeit in gleicher
arbeitszeit gleiche renten vergleiche
lebensleistung und endlich eine
angemessene beteiligung der ostdeutschen
an politischen juristischen kulturellen
wissenschaftlichen
gewerkschaftlichen und ökonomischen
führungsposition
ich sage den alten ostdeutschen immer
dass sie klüger sein als sie hören und
investor
dann sage ich ja ihr kennt zwei systeme
die andere nur eins und wenn sie ihre
diesbezüglichen erfahrungen auch die
jüngeren vermitteln werden auch diese
klüger ich freue mich dass im osten der
widerstandsgeist gegen
ungleichbehandlung wächst genau das
müssen wir unterstützen und
wenn wir uns
wenn wir uns auf diese fünf fragen
konzentrierten haben wir eine chance
wenn wir dagegen ein laden für die 1000
kleinen dinge bleiben berauben wir uns
dieser chance und wir müssen uns
und wir müssen uns entscheiden wessen
interessen wir zu vertreten haben ich
sage es ganz klar nach meiner auffassung
in erster linie die interessen der
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
dazu gehören
dazu gehören natürlich auch die
ehemaligen arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer dh die rentnerinnen und
rentner und die kommenden
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer das
heißt die kinder und jugendlichen die
auszubildenden und die studierenden wir
müssen die kraft sein die sich verstärkt
für die rechte für die chancen und die
möglichkeiten der arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer einsetzt zu den
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern
würden selbstverständlich auch die
angestellten und danach nach dieser
ersten gruppe deren interessen wir
zuvorderst zu vertreten haben stehen wir
auch für die interessen der arbeitslosen
hartz 4 beziehen der obdachlosen und der
geflüchteten 1 wir müssen entschiedene
gegner eine einteilung von geflüchteten
in flüchtlinge erster zweiter und
dritter klasse bleiben
wir kümmern uns auch um die interessen
der beamtinnen und beamten der solo
selbstständigen der freiberuflichen und
freiberufler der inhaberinnen und
inhaber kleiner und mittelständischer
unternehmen
der mittelstand will dass endlich die
großen konzerne und banken angemessen
steuerlich herangezogen werden und er
nicht alles allein zu bezahlen hat wir
wollen das auch es wird höchste zeit
wenn mittelstand und linke 1 kein
bündnis eingehen in dieser frage werden
sie über eine angemessene besteuerung
der banken und konzerne nur quatschen
aber sie nicht erreichen nur mit einem
bündnis ist das durchsetzbar ich habe
ein weiteres angebot
ich habe ein weiteres anliegen ich war
mal in einer einheitspartei und bin froh
dass wir das überwunden haben und in
unserer partei verschiedene auffassungen
vertreten werden aber unsere existenz
krise liegt auch daran dass in der
öffentlichkeit nicht erkennbar ist was
eigentlich mehrheitsmeinungen und was
minderheitsmeinung in unserer partei
sind wir müssen dafür sorgen dass das
für alle wieder öffentlich wahrnehmbar
wird
was wir überwinden müssen
was wir mit binden müssen ist das klima
der denunziation
fast alles was negatives über
genossinnen und genossen in den
zeitungen steht oder sonstwo
veröffentlicht wird ist von anderen
genossinnen und genossen mitgeteilt
worden das ist unerträglich
das
das was ich an den grünen schätze ist
dass sie sich nicht weniger streiten als
wir aber man so gut wie nichts davon in
den medien liest wird oder sieht unser
schreibt ist schon in den medien bevor
er überhaupt stattgefunden hat es ist
höchste zeit die denunziation zu
beerdigen
wir haben
wir haben mit den genannten fragen ein
wert für die gesellschaft und neben
einen platz ein den keine andere partei
ersetzen kann weder die spd geschweige
denn die grünen dieses land braucht
demokratische sozialistinnen und
sozialisten
ich habe
ich habe eine schwere existenzkrise
einer partei erlebt das war 1989 90
massen ausdrückte immer wieder wurde mir
eingeredet dass es gar keinen sinn mache
dass sich jetzt auch bleiben lassen soll
aber es gab keine andere partei die
bereit weil die interessen derjenigen
aus der ddr zu vertreten die angst vor
der deutschen einheit hatten die wussten
dass ihre bisherigen leistungen nichts
mehr galten oder die später feststellten
dass entgegen ihrer erwartung aus ihnen
nichts wurde es gab keine vereinigung
nur ein anschluss und es musste eine
partei geben die diese interessen
vertrag gleichzeitig aber die
selbstkritische aufarbeitung der eigenen
biografien forderte diejenigen die in
der partei blieben haben dann mit
leidenschaft mit solidarität gemeinsam
gekämpft gegen alle widerstände und
genau das wünsche ich mir jetzt hört
auch mit dem ganzen kleinkarierten
müsste in unserer partei wir müssen
entschlossen entschieden
leidenschaftlich und in solidarität mit
einer der ab heute streiten und kämpfen
[Applaus]